[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce par 78 spécial salon
du golf au programme
guilhem miranda avec fly over green
il a filmé grâce aux drones tous les
parcours de golf et avec book points
goal of il propose d' incroyable
avantage aux golfeurs nous rencontrerons
aussi dit l'un d'eux la chaise il a
trouvé une solution idéale pour ceux qui
en ont assez de trimballer leur club en
avion arrêt en italie avec les superbes
chaussures de remo de raimondi et les
potters incroyable de dario trintignant
nous terminerons cette visite en
poussant un cocorico labeur dit mort de
david arnaud qui vous baladera sur vos
parcours préférés et française
[Musique]
alors bienvenue au salon du golf je suis
avec eux ils aiment de miranda debout
points goal l'ailé d heroes le faire
peut-être pas votre visage mais vous
connaissent tous parce que fly over
green qui se ce moyen de te connaître
dès les parcours de golf de doubler ses
films et ses goûts oui tout à fait il ya
maintenant huit ans donc on a commencé
en 2010 avec nos propres drones à chimay
gratuitement ici mais déjà des drones
on les a fabriquées oui sauf qu'à
l'époque et ça n'existait pas vraiment
et on a fabriqué des premiers drogue qui
permettait de survoler tout un parcours
et de le montrer sur internet chez
interbox et à l'époque de dieu début de
youtube
c'est un prémisse évidemment s'est
développée depuis tout à fait
aujourd'hui on sait que les médias en
ligne sont très importants on cherche
toujours à voir des vidéos des photos on
a aujourd'hui plus de 15000 vidéo 80
mille photos aériennes dans 450 golf etc
voilà de faire un gros réseau de de golf
et des golfeurs on voulait trouver sur
youtube en effet on peut les trouver sur
les sites des golfs ou sur les sites
école est là et évidemment ça a un
intérêt tout le golfeur français qui
veulent s'en sédition a parfois même sur
leur propre parce que c'est quand même
beau de voir comment le vélo à tout à
fait oui mais ça c'est aussi très utile
pour les pour les étrangers qui veulent
venir jouer en france par tout à fait
nous toutes les vidéos sont intégrés
directement sur les sites internet des
agences de voyages à l'étranger
donc ça permet d'avoir une plus grande
visibilité internationale pour les golfs
à moins de beaucoup
et et donc des golfeurs étrangers qui
souhaitent faire un séjour en france de
découvrir les golfs sans bouger de chez
eux
comment vous est née cette idée de faire
ça mais en fait l'idée était de proposer
de découvrir les golfs d'une manière un
petit peu différente qu'une simple photo
des vidéos qu'on avait l'habitude de
voir des golfeurs qui tapait dans l'air
mais et les 2008 2009 était vraiment le
côté drôle mais enfin il fallait avoir
l'idée d'utiliser cette voie là et de
proposer ce à moindre coût les golfs
avait pas forcément besoin
voyez pas forcément lu ting et donc on
l'a proposé dans un premier temps
complètement gratuitement dès maintenant
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on demande un
petit abonnement annuel
et franchement utile pour voilà comment
on essaie de proposer un bon service à
moindre coût avec des mises à jour
régulières
ça s'est mal à ça c'est la chose pour
laquelle vous êtes tous les golfeurs
connaissent pas ce que nous vivons tous
sur internet voir quand on va aux
joueurs parcours on va regarder avant
comment il est et vous avez pratiquement
tous les golfs de france a à peu près 70
à 80% des gold commerciaux français oui
alors beaucoup un golf
il faut que vous expliquer ce que c'est
parce que ça c'est je passais plus tôt
mais en tout cas c'est peut-être les
gens connaissent plus d'être un peu
moins et c'est très utile et 7h alors
new business model est tournée sur deux
les changes dans le sens où lorsqu'on
fait une prestation si le golf ne
souhaite pas pays
on lui propose de lui acheter des greens
fille d'accord à dire que si le golf du
doigt 1000 euros on va dire mais écoutez
on va vous achetez 1000 euros ni leur
train de vie 9 comme ça vous sortez pas
d'argent nous tous et green fie aux
nappes de dix mille par an on va les
proposer à nos golfeurs à moindre coût
sur www.gout.ch notre marque était
d'accord mais on les revend d'une
certaine manière
de manière un peu intelligente non dans
le sens je voulais golfe ne voulait pas
trop qu'on compte des stands un peu
tarifs du benfica ses voiles sont très
connus c'est qu'on proposait qu'une
fille même plein pot mais on est humble
hôtel par exemple
donc je vais vous dire où les la can
proposer le royal mougins et le old
course online et je vais vous offrir un
hôtel à 200 euros en plein centre de
cannes c'est bien donc ça dénature pas
le tarif du golfe
c'est un cadeau au plus on a fait des
beaux négociations avec les hôtels de la
même manière sauf que les hôtels on a au
fait les vidéos on échange de nuitées
d'accord donc tout ça ça nous permet
d'avoir des package très intéressant
c'est génial pour l'épauler golfeur
comme on dit c'est une expression que
c'est gagnant gagnant
on essaie d'avoir un petit accord
tripartite que l'école s'y retrouve avec
tous les services dont ils ont besoin
que les golfeurs s'y retrouvent avec des
package sympa donc confiants aussi des
golfs passe à moindre coût
et l'idée c'est vraiment voilà de
proposer à cet écosystème un nouveau une
nouvelle forme de de communication mais
de ceux dont les golfs ont vraiment
besoin aussi parce que c'est ce qu'on
pense qu'il faut laisser reposer quand
même temps tout à fait guilhem me ronald
autre facette de boue coin golf c'est le
système de caisses cette gestion que
vous proposez au goal voilà donc nous on
a remarqué en huit ans que peu de golf
mais juste en parlant pour la france
avait la possibilité de mettre un bon
système de caisse il nous gérer leur
goal laquelle gestion ou si un jour vous
allez rien pour toi mais depuis le 1er
janvier 2018 c'est obligatoire d'avoir
un système à gré d'accord donc nous on a
ce système là et on essaie de le
proposer à tous les golfs à moindre coût
mais non seulement le propose à moindre
coût donc à 99 euros par mois
oui d'accord mais en plus on va le
proposer via un module sur leur site
internet qui va permettre à n'importe
quel golfeur non seulement d'acheter à
green fille mais également d'acheter
n'importe quel article qui existe
actuellement dans le prochain spider
prochain plus proche en temps réel oui
c'est pas juste le green point là c'est
des prochains voilà c'est par exemple
ils habitent ces pages habite toulouse
bordeaux et je veux des ryder cup qui
sont en deuil national voilà comment je
vais aller pour aller sur le site du
golf national
d'un côté le produit sans acheter même
lure une fille les verts livret à livret
à bordeaux voilà mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est surtout pour les
golfeurs étrangers absolument sonné en
anglais on vient jouer par exemple au
touquet mais c'est intéressant d'acheter
son gré une fille mais peut-être
d'acheter des goodies parce que en ligne
ont valu d'avoir moins cher et lorsqu'on
arrive on n'a plus de carte bleue à m ce
que on a déjà fait au pire on change la
taille d'une polo mais on a déjà acheté
on n'a plus qu'à aller jouer c'est à
dire et ça permet aux pro shop de mieux
s'organiser aussi de mieux gérer leurs
stocks
parce que l'on est et donc de vendre
plus en ligne
parce qu'actuellement sont actuellement
oui si c'est le cas c'est pas le cas
encore voilà c'est pas le gars d'autres
bugs on peut aller sur votre site
évidemment www.nyc.gov point golfe
et puis et puis fly over green keeper
continue de notre côté des vidéos et là
on a fait beaucoup la californie la
floride
on va faire venir de plus en plus
américain aussi sur le sol européen pour
découvrir nos beaux parcours de golf et
vous avez un stand au salon du golf qui
ne désemplit pas innocente a fait depuis
ce matin où il ya du monde parce que on
propose dont tous les produits services
mais aussi des produits dont on fabrique
des gants fabrique des petits attrapa
les petits guides et accessoires que les
voilà on les fabrique les attrape alors
fabriquée à nantes et ça permet oui ça
n'existait pas notez que c'est vraiment
il fait tous et guilhem miranda bol
voilà on essaie de proposer tout ce dont
lé golfe ont besoin
merci merci merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors toujours au salon du golf et je
suis avec ghislain de la chaise le
maccabi master.com je suis ravi de vous
rencontrer parce que vous avez une
solution formidable pour les gens qui
voyagent et qui voit là ne veulent pas
nous nos vies parce que c'est cher c'est
compliqué d'en porter leur club
voilà effectivement c'est devenu un peu
un calvaire un pain sommes d'emmener son
matériel quand on veut jouer au golf
dans des destinations un peu sympa
ensoleillé et on se disait que ça
pouvait être sympa d'avoir une solution
simple on pouvait choisir à l'avant son
matériel et la récupérer directement sur
place et tout ça comment comment on fait
il ya un site
et tout ça pour moins cher que de
l'emmener être payé des excédents de
bagages parce que des actions ça
commence à chiffrer exactement bagré
imposant alors comment ça se passe hier
votre site
c'est le week end master.com mike est
dit master.com on peut taper location de
clubs directement sur google pour nous
trouver
mais mike a dit master.com permet de
choisir son matériel de personnaliser
son sac et de pouvoir se faire livrer
son matériel ou à l'aéroport en arrivant
ou bien dans le coffre de sa voiture de
location away ou bien directement à
l'hôtel au moment de l'apéro c'est
vachement bien voilà et tout ça à partir
de 5 euros par jour ce qui est par ce
qui est vraiment passé alors quelque
chose de pire des cas la bouée des
mythiques son hôte d'un soir soit les
clubs qui jouent soit s'il veut essayer
des clubs nouveau il ne fait alors c'est
ça l'idée c'est de se dire qu'on a une
possibilité supplémentaire quand on part
en vacances on peut essayer des clubs
récent de qualité sur le parcours et ça
peut éventuellement donner les petites
envies de change d'achat et lala exact
donc c'est ça il ça permet d'essayer des
câbles mais aussi on veut jouer avec ses
propres clubs de les retrouver et pas
être perdu
c'est une idée absolument formidable
voilà c'est pour éviter d'être d'être le
jean claude luche l'adieu google vous
est arrivé une histoire personnelle
vous avez du mal alors transportée au
club moi je suis passionné par le golf
passionnés par le golfe depuis que je
suis née et j'ai épousé une femme qui
n'était pas forcément passionnés elle
aime beaucoup jouer quand il fait beau
quand il fait chaud mais tranquille mais
pas autant que moi alors la question se
pose toujours quand on part en vacances
est ce que on emmène les clubs ou pas
alors elle est plutôt pour ne pas les
emmener chez vous c'est le couvre les
prendre et moi je me dis que si je joue
pas au golf pendant les vacances c'est
pas des vraies vacances
donc lorsque je partais par exemple à
l'île maurice
j'avais toujours ce problème de prendre
non seulement mon sac et le 6e en plus
du sien plus les bagages et avoir tous
les problèmes de hors format et de coûts
avec les clubs je pense que vous êtes
dit faut que je trouve une solution
tous les golfeurs qui voyagent ce que
j'appelle les colts trotter finalement
qu'on progresse pour la ses problèmes
je pense que vous reconnaissez si si je
vous parle de tracas
au moment de transporter vos clubs et
aujourd'hui
bon on a une solution qui est je pense
qu'à ses astra c'est génial
vous travaillez sur quelle destination
alors on est à faro à lisbonne et à
porto au portugal week end grandes
destinations golfiques il fait chaud il
fait beau à peu près tout est des
parcours absolument exceptionnel que je
vous invite à les tester
c'est juste à côté de de la france avec
les low cost aujourd'hui pour moins de
100 euros quasiment vous pouvez y aller
donc se passer le week-end là bas c'est
sympa on est aussi à l'île maurice de
vous décider d'ouvrir à l'île maurice
on est ravis on est également à palma de
majorque on est à paris pour soutenir la
ryder cup parce que je pense que j'ai un
peu mal également d'anglais d'américains
d'amis de provence d'amyle province qui
veulent venir au golf national et qu'ils
n'ont pas envie de se la péter avec
leurs sacs de neuf et on est présent
aussi pour offrir ce service qu'en
france et vous avez un partenariat avec
une marque de location de voitures hertz
a exactement m et qui nous permet d'être
stratégiquement plutôt bien placé et
faciles à trouver dans les aéroports
quand
comme voulait récupérer votre sac vous
sortez de l'avion vous suivez loueur de
voiture et vous tombez sur hertz et
c'est là qu'on a laissé la clause est à
rita d'accord mais il vaut mieux avoir
loué ses comptes avant sur le site
alors oui master.com voilà ce que vous
pouvez les choisir vous pouvez
personnaliser votre sac et vous êtes
sûrs de leur dispo voilà c'est une île
c'est divinement qui va plaire à tous
les golfeurs qui aime voyager découvrir
des parcours à l'étranger
donc voilà on va sur mac et du blaster
coin comme léon voyage léger en voyage d
j'ai envoyé sans rien on choisit ses
club des clubs qui vous plaît des clubs
que vous voulez essayer
et puis rav récupère sur dans la voiture
soit long terme soit au club social
maliki dit master.com merci beaucoup
qu'il est imprécise merci mille fois
merci
[Musique]
les bellissima scalpel des réponses de
révolte et nos partenaires italiens
j'ai désolé je ne parle pas italien vous
parlez je dis parce que monsieur
répondit et vous allez traduire vous
avez vous travaillé avec lui vous parler
français alors l'autre une entreprise
raymond 10 et dates de quoi de trois
générations oui un peu près un croc
génération et fait des chaussures de
golf depuis une vingtaine d'années
vingtaine d'années voilà c'est déjà sur
la raison sont géniales sont magnifiques
les clients peuvent les adapter à leurs
souhaits on peut personnaliser les
chaussures à tous les goûts et à tous
les souhaits c'est des chaussures faite
entièrement à la main et de façon
artisanale et sur mesure est survenue
voilà vous habille le pied voilà si on
aime le rouge on peut prendre celles là
sont vraiment magnifiques
on a une vaste gamme de couleurs de
matériaux et des tissus tous est un
charlot tous et toutes ses chances au
dos et un châle ou alors vous êtes
italien ça c'est dit d'où médine italie
les deux quelle ville voudrait un texte
ou encore en corée
madame adriatique il ya évidemment vous
êtes en italie et en france en vedette
entend distribuer malheureusement il n'y
a pas de magasin qui distribue la marque
en france
la plupart des points de vente sont à
l'italie oui et on a quand même un point
de vente à dubaï pour le marché
asiatique asiatiques
et puis il ya le site ww points ribordy
golf point com alors là on peut
commander de france des chaussures
toutes les mettre à son goût avec les
couleurs qu'on veut demander les
couleurs qu'on veut et vous livrer tout
à fait alors l'important c'est que
chaque client s affiche où son dossier
dans notre base de données
avec toutes les mesures des pieds levés
pied qui évoluent au cours de temps et
donc on vérifie en fait la portabilité
et la beauté dignité et le client n'a
plus qu'à choisir le modèle de
chaussures les couleurs et sa
personnalisation et s'est fait dès les
chaussures magnifique c'est vrai que
valent ils c'est vrai que l'italie et la
chaussure c'est un mariage qui va
ensemble le design design
bravo bravo merci bien
[Musique]
et
encore le design italien après des
chaussures les potters de dario
stratégie bonjour voila comme dario ne
pas le kit à bien présenter ce travail
c'est un travail artistique absolument
extraordinaire c'est peut-être en bois
oui absolument
donc en fait ce sont des créations
uniques unique de dario qui représente
la société
dargaud qui vient de bologne en italie
et en fait c'est un golfeur c'est un
passionné de golf et il s'est mis donc à
faire des productions de potter donc ils
sont tous réalisés en bois en bois
différents bois
et cuir et toutes sont bien sûr des
pièces uniques c'est les pièces vie
c'est pas seulement des pièces de
collection ou peu joué
non on peut jouer avec un volume en non
seulement ils sont qui l'on joue avec
mais en plus ils sont très beaux et de
qualité sur tout et de qualité oui sont
magnifiques ils rappellent parfois voilà
on voit des clubs aux siens il rappelle
aussi le design d'aider des clubs aux
siens de dénoncer potter donc c'est
vraiment magnifique
voilà alors si vous avez le bon matériel
si vous aimez de ces clubs petit é voilà
vous nous nous amène à la fois dans le
passé et puis dans le futur parce qu'on
peut jouer avec le mieux s'insérer sur
le site parce que c'est là que vous
trouverez ces a dude potter ce point
comme à 12 go baroud peeters computer
salon du golf en france et tous les
salons de golf le picard meslot
merci bravo d'avéo brabois dario qu'ils
arrêtent dario merci see
[Musique]
toujours au salon du golf avec david
dargaud de france bord alors franchement
que vous présentez une machine s'appelle
labeur du bord exactement
décrivez est ce que c'est que l'on va la
découvrir
alors c'est une machine qui a été créé
inventé et mise au point depuis quatre
ans depuis 2014 et elle est hautement
française totalement de français c'est
que des artisans français qu'on
travaillait dessus
les packs batterie se fait par une
société qui se base qui est basée à
valence qui la société reyes tout ce qui
est protection c'est la société courbis
à valence et tout ce qui est posée
l'accent drôme et du vaucluse et toute
la partie aluminium est faite par une
société qui s'appelle mcm à camaret sur
aygues donc c'est donc c'est totalement
français et totalement français et monte
dessus peut-être aurais-je dû monter
tiers s'est porté sur celle là aussi moi
c'est simple je risque par contre c'est
stable dans l'utilisation de la machine
b bien sûr c'est pour jouer c'est pour
jouer sur les parcours de golf à jouer
sur les parcours
on tourne en appuyant la droite en
appuyant sur un skateboard exactement
c'est le même système de
qu'un skate board c'est très très stable
très très stable
la machine pèse 48 kg c'est ce qui fait
aussi sa stabilité ont même sac devant
on le voit sur la vôtre évidemment il ya
il ya deux avantages cette bassine
d'abord on va plus vite on joue plus
vite vous faire un parcours encore à
bomber gagne une heure sur une île pour
deux heures exactement trois heures
trois heures et demie sur un parcours de
cinq heures c'est moins fatigant et
c'est ludique en marche - et c'est
ludique mais voilà c'est l'aspect c'est
l'aspect de la machine all à la prison
mince et rapide la prise en main ses
deux trous d'accord voilà qu'on part
dieu on arrive à la fin du 2 e aux src
servir de la machine et osez vous avez
pas dotés thaksin alors pas d'accord je
vais pas pris je n'ai pas les places
ayant encore d'accidents dramatiques et
non
donc voilà c'est vrai que celle ci et
c'est la grande mode saas et de proposer
au fond il ya le golfe puis l'amusement
autour du gol parce qu'on peut c'est
vrai que ça fait des figures entoure
mais c'est très très plaisant et comme
on disait c'est très ludique de jouer
avec une avec une machine comme ça 16
c'est pour cette raison qu'elle a un peu
été inventé la machine c'est parce que
je trouvais que au golf en avc 18,3
faire et entre chaque trouble on
s'enduit un petit peu nicolas et ce qui
est génial c'est que encore une fois je
le répète les c'est important c'est made
in france pas exactement fabrication
entièrement mellie francon ni tony on y
tenait pour pouvoir proposer une machine
de qualité alors
on la trouve où et comment est ce qu est
ce que vous voulez vous est plutôt
distribuées dans les golfs et on les
loue dans les golfs ou est-ce que ça
s'achète
alors on a beaucoup de contacts
aujourd'hui de particuliers qui
voudraient les acheter mais c'est une
machine qui est quasiment un
transportable mais une fois et par sa
taille donc c'est une machine qui est
destiné aux jeunes l'occasion à la
location et ça serait à eux deux
de faire le travail de louer ces
machines au golf et de devenir peut-être
rajeunir un peu l'image du golf
absolument pas ce que ça tu iras parce
que c'est vrai qu'il ya problème du
golfe pour les jeunes comment attirer
les jeunes c'est un des moyens de les
attirer des gens pour des cons vous êtes
en train de prospecter
non on est en train de prospecter on
commercialise la machine depuis trois
mois
oui c'est toi sale et c'est tout récent
on se lance voilà mais ce qu'on fait de
course le premier qui arrive dans le mur
a daigné aller avec plaisir
[Musique]
david dargaud merci une autre machine
qui est celle d'une grande gueule chose
qui s'appelle agathe sauzon que le
numéro 2 française c'est ça c'est notre
ambassadrice aller de chez nous est
notamment allé à l'est de valence
exactement
on a la chance de la voir sur notre
territoire donc là n'est pas là
aujourd'hui
et en fait on aurait aimé l'avoir mais à
l'arrivée australie voilà un peu ça
c'est sa machine
la voulait de cette couleur là donc on
lui a fait spécialement une machine
blanche avec les couleurs de l'équipe de
france
mélanger la peur du beurre de ses
labeurs du board
et elle s'en sert pour ses entraînements
donc maintenant la prochaine étape c'est
lé golfe qui vous pouvez
mais les gones qui vont nous faire
confiance et ça mais y'a pas de raison
qu'il bouffe et bannissez français
encore une fois exactement exactement
donc c'est une belle machine ludique qui
est dans l'esprit du sport et j'espère
qu'il va mais qui va faire avancer le ce
sport qu'est le golf dans le bon sens
pour rajeunir un peu c'est sa clientèle
et ses passionnés les ces passionnés
mais je vous ai jamais dire quelque
chose de rester un peu comme ça ça
serait pas mal et c'est vrai mais on va
le retenir en tête cherchent une
position merci et bravo david o
je rappelle alors la société s'appelle
franck borde france board et la machine
s'appelle son burger world et en espère
que d'ici quelques mois on va le trouver
dans plein de la baie on espère aussi on
la joue et on l'espère aussi merci à
vous merci et bravo avant
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]